[Music]
welcome everybody to our webinar
enrichment and analysis of rare antigen
and virus-specific t-cells
in the next 45 minutes you will learn
about miltoni biotech's extensive
antigen-specific and virus-specific
t-cell portfolio including relevant
application data and workflows
so enjoy let's begin with a brief
company presentation
miltoni biotech was founded in 1989 by
stephan milton himself
and is the largest owner managed company
in germany
we have two main sites in germany one in
berges-gladbach where the headquarters
are located
and one in tether row where the gmp
manufacturing facility is located
we have subsidiaries in 28 countries and
additionally
distribute in 73 more countries
currently we employ over 3 000 employees
worldwide
our mission is to serve the needs in
life science research
and to translate new scientific findings
into clinical applications
in the current situation with the covet
19 pandemic it has never been more
important to have powerful tools at your
disposal
for an efficient work with antigen or
better in this case
virus specific t cells sarskoff
ii as cause of the novel respiratory
disease covid19
exhibits high infection rates in number
of cases worldwide
with partially severe causes of disease
and even fatalities
this has severe social and economic
consequences
so we need to act now miltoni biotech
does its best to support your
virus-specific tesa research
let's have a first look on how we can
define angiogen
specific t cells of course all t
cells are antigen specific however that
term hereby is applied to t cells that
were activated prior to analysis via
their cognate antigen
and not by an artificial polyclonal
stimulus
hereby only t cells of the given
specificity are activated
and cloningly expand the initial
frequency of a t cell of a certain
specificity is however
very low analysis of antigen-activated
t-cells is important to understand the
very basics of the immune response
and plays a pivotal role not only in
infectious diseases
but also in tumor immunology
autoimmunity eledrology
and many more a little more detailed
look is depicted on the right side
upon antigen-specific activation t-cells
clonally expand
upright activation markers and release
cytokines
thus assessment of those markers and
cytokines as well as proliferation are
valuable tools
for the analysis of antigen-activated
t-cells
some molecules are of outstanding
importance when it comes to diesel
activation
and serve as good activation indicators
cd69 has an early pawn t cell activation
marker
cd 25 the il-2 receptor
has a later activation marker on all
conventional t-cells but
also as regulatory t cell marker
cd 137 also called for 1bb
as suitable cd8 positive conventional
diesel activation marker
but also as early activation marker on
regulatory t-cells
and cd154 also called
cd40 ligand as ideal conventional
cd4 t cell activation marker with a very
low background
and finally of course cytokines for the
functional analysis of the
antigen-activated t-cells
generally analysis methods for antigen
specific t cells can be classified into
two categories
first the direct analysis methods
labeling of the specific tcr using
recombinant mhc peptide multimeters
identifies
cells directly according to their
specific antigen receptor
without restriction to a certain
functional parameter
hereby class 1 mhc peptide multimers are
widely used to quantify
and characterize antigen-specific
cd8-positive diesel responses
the construction of class 2 multimeters
for cd4 t-cell analysis
is more difficult due to differences of
the mhc structure
and tcr affinity
however recently as some advancements
have been made in this field
still this method is more frequently
applied to cd8 positive diesel analysis
and lacks somewhat cd4 t cell
applicability
however the major limitation of the
tetramere or multimeter technology
is that the antigenic epitope has to be
characterized in detail
that is a defined peptide restricted to
a particular mhc haplotype
second we have the indirect analysis
methods
this category employs functional
parameters such as expression of
aforementioned activation markers and
cytokines
but also cytotoxicity and proliferation
as an indirect readout
for t cells which react to a specific
antigen challenge
the detection of antigen specific t
cells by functional parameters requires
the prior in vitro stimulation with the
specific antigen
for stimulation peptides peptide pools
proteins or lysates can be used covering
here by
all possible t cell epitopes the
advantage of these activation methods is
that they are independent of
mhc alleles or exact definition of the
antigenic epitopes
however the assays depend on the
presence of a sufficient number of
functional antigen presenting cells
and per definition exclude energy key
cells from the analysis
most importantly the biggest advantage
here is that
all relevant information can be obtained
using flow cytometry based assays
and selective markers allow for
additional cell isolation or enrichment
in the following slides we will
especially have a look at the indirect
analysis methods
for antigen-specific t-cells to have a
complete view on the functional
characteristics of these
interesting cells
however as advanced the different
approaches for the analysis of
antigen-specific t-cells are
there are quite some challenges that
need to be faced
the most difficult challenge of course
is the rarity of t
cells of a given specificity depending
on the individual experience of the
donor
as well as of the antigen itself
frequencies can vary between 0.1 percent
down to 0.001 percent of the whole t
cell population in addition to that
sometimes those rare cells are difficult
to isolate for example when working with
solid tissue
also it needs to be determined which
cytokines and markers one wants actually
to look at
here again the specific circumstances
and goals need to be taken into
consideration
we will have a closer look at these
challenges learn about individual
experimental solutions
and have examples of successful
applications
in the end it is indeed like finding the
needle in the haystack
as outlined before the frequency of
antigen-specific t-cells can vary
depending
on the circumstances and is one of the
biggest challenges for the analysis
all the more it is important to
optimally prepare the starting material
without losing pressure cells
furthermore only a low background
enables to efficiently
find the desired cell population as it
helps to drastically increase
sensitivity in detection
of course specific labeling no matter if
for the cell enrichment or flow analysis
is essential to lower the background
to efficiently isolate detect and
analyze
antigen-specific t cells an optimized
procedure during every step of the
workflow is essential
from sample preparation to cell culture
to enrichment and finally to flow
analysis
military biotech combines different
technologies over the whole workflow
to maximize success when working with
rare antigen-specific t-cells
the whole workflow of course should be
optimized
and the right product combination is the
key
however why are especially t cells so
fundamental
for an efficient antivirus response
apart from the innate immunity and
b-cell-mediated antibody
response t-cells play a central role in
the body's anti-virus defense
for example by killing of virus infected
cells directly
but also by supporting the besa response
all these parts of the human immune
response are complementary for an
efficient antivirus immune response
consequently only assessing antibody
serology does not give the full picture
the very specific tissue response has
also to be analyzed
from infectious diseases and viruses
like mers
and sarskoff 1 that are closely related
to covid19
we know of the important role of
virus-specific t cells for an efficient
antivirus immune response
as zhao at al state in science
immunology
as well as other recent publications the
role of t cells
in coronavirus virus-related infection
these infectious diseases is essential
for
the analysis of the population's immune
status in epidemiological
studies the prognosis for disease
progress and treatment options for virus
infections
for long-term protection provided by
virus-specific memory t
cells as a target point for vaccine
development
and finally also for monitoring the
efficacy of a vaccine
please follow the links on the upper and
lower right side to find the respective
publications in pubmed
however to analyze the rare
virus-specific t-cells efficiently
several parameters have to be fulfilled
sensitivity for the most precise results
speed for higher throughput simple
procedures
for a lower error rate a multi-parameter
analysis
for all crucial factors and
reproducibility
for higher reliability and miltoni
biotech has of course the fitting
solutions
so let's have a look at the in vitro
workflow when analyzing antigen-specific
t
cells first pbmcs including t
cells are isolated from a donor sample
however in any case antigen-presenting
cells need to be present to prime the t
cells with the given antigen
within the pbmc context this is already
the case
consequently when working with isolated
t cells
added antigen presenting cells have to
be co-cultured
the cells are stimulated with the
antigen of interest
for example using virus peptide pools
after a stimulation phase of several
hours the antigen specific t
cells get activated upregulate certain
surface markers
and secrete functional cytokines
now cells can be stained intra and
extracellularly
to assess phenotype on cytokine
expression
additionally secreted cytokines can be
analyzed in the cell calcium
supernatants
before the analysis rare
antigen-specific t cells
may be pre-enriched finally
cells can now be analyzed by a flow
cytometry
to assess the quality and functionality
of the antigen-specific t-cell response
a successful experimental workflow
starts with efficient sample preparation
the most widely used source for
antigen-specific t
cells are pbmcs they contain both the
antigen-specific t
cells as well as the antigen presenting
cells and thereby
provide a functional immunological
context for the analysis of
antigen-activated t-cells
usually pbmcs are prepared via density
gradient centrifugation
however when working with for example
compromised samples
contaminated samples very small
small samples or very rare cells
density-grade incentivization can be
very tedious inefficient
inefficient and even dangerous
here recovery of every cell counts
with the pbmc isolation kit small blood
volumes ranging from 1 to 10 milliliters
can be easily processed within 25
minutes
to obtain highly pure pbmcs with a high
recovery
the max prep pbmc isolation kit
eliminates user dependent
inconsistencies
and performs reliably for every
separation
and is a very valuable solution
please follow the link in the
sub-headline to get the respective
product page
however under certain disease conditions
tissue infiltrating antigen-specific
t-cells might be of interest
in this step valuable cells can be
easily lost due to inefficient tissue
dissociation
or harsh digest conditions especially
with the rare cells
again every prepared cell counts
our hallmark product here is the
gentlemax tissue dissociator
the gentle dissociation preserves cell
epitopes and recovers efficiently
precious immune cells
even from hard to processed tissue
samples
being programmable the performance is
highly reproducible
it is fast since with the gentlemax up
to 8 samples can be processed in
parallel
with the heaters you can control the
temperature for optimal performance
and finally with the sterile enclosed
tubes you work in a safe and closed
system
the perfect addition to the gentlemax
are our tissue dissociation kits
they combine enzymatic treatment with
the gentle max mechanical dissociation
t-cells can be isolated with ease even
from difficult
human and mouse tissue such as spleen
tumor
lung liver skin brain and lamina propria
the combination of the genital max
dissociate and the tissue dissociation
kits
guarantee high yield best
reproducibility
and most gentle dissociation for the
preservation of epitopes
and thereby optimal recovery of rare and
delicate cells
please again follow the link in the
sub-headline to get to the respective
product page
after preparing target cells for example
pbmcs
a crucial step in the workflow is the
antigen-specific stimulation of the
t-cells
hereby the most efficient
antigen-specific stimulation of t-cells
is achieved reliably with our peptide
peptide pools
these extensive panels of virus tumor
fungi or microbiota specific antigens
consists of 50 mere peptides with 11
amino acid overlaps
covering the complete sequence of the
respective antigen
the peptide composition ensures the
optimal stimulation of both cd4
and cd8 t cells moreover
milton is peptivators are water-soluble
and do not have to be diluted in harmful
dmso
peptides are available in different
quality grades as well as in a
convenient 96 well format for high
throughput applications
the different poly quality grades
include research grade
premium grade and even max gmp grade
most notably we recently added sarskoff
ii protein s protein n and protein m
peptides to our portfolio to support
your research
best in these difficult times please
follow the respective links to get to
the peptivata product pages
as listed here the many specificities of
our peptida peptide pools
cover the most important antigens
ranging from various viruses
such as cmv and ebv
of course also including sarskoff ii two
for example gp100 melon a two candida
albicans as well as to auto antigens
like insulin
on the right side you can see how
efficiently peptidated peptide pools
stimulate cd4
cd8 t cells hereby assessed by
interferon gamma expression
after stimulation peptivators ht
provide quality synthetic peptide pools
to enable high throughput applications
assemble your customized essay by simply
combining modular antigen specific
strips
on a single plate this level of absolute
flexibility
leaves you in full control of your
experimental setup
a control strip can also be easily added
more flexibility
greater convenience and comprehensive
support for the
from the experts in t cells
of course flow cytometry is the most
widely used method to analyze
antigen and virus-specific t-cells
however even an established method like
low cytometry
has its limits and challenges as
antigen-specific t-cells can be
extremely rare and
evade detection as described
by bachelorette colleagues in current
opinions of pharmacology
in 2015 despite its high sensitivity
standard flow of cytometry is limited by
the number of events
which can be acquired typically around 1
million cells
as well as sustaining background which
is typically between 0.01
and 0.1 this restricts the analysis to
populations occurring at frequencies
lower than
0.01 to 0.1 percent
in absence of acute infections frequency
of antigen-specific memory cells
can typically be in the range of one
cell within 100
to one cell within 100 000
however many functionally important t
cell populations
occur at much lower frequencies for
example t
cells specific for certain viruses auto
antigens
tumor antigens environmental antigens or
neo antigens
are typically below 0.01 percent
they cannot be assessed without
additional measures
such as pre-enrichment and reduction of
the flow background
so of course ideally use max microbeads
for the pre-enrichment
moreover to keep background during flow
analysis to a minimum
specific labeling and bright
fluorophores are a prerequisite
the use of reaffinity recombinant
antibodies in our bright propriety
biodie conjugates
maximizes these efforts later we will
hear more about that
you can also follow the link in the two
last bullet points to get more info
about reaffinity recombinant antibodies
and our biodies
so what makes our microbeads max
technology so special and the ideal tool
for the pre-enrichment
of rare and fragile cells the gold
standard so to say
under the motto select the best we
describe the advantage of our column
technology
minimal labeling with no effects on cell
biology for full downstream
compatibility the column amplifies the
magnetic field
10 000 fold this allows for minimal
labeling in smallest bead size
in consequence less epitopes are covered
on the cell surface
and less stress is applied on the cells
the color matrix allows for the most
gentle sorting since there is a large
space between the steel spheres around
20 times the size of a single lymphocyte
and thousands of publications agree
and on the right side you can see the
consequences
more left panel shows color-free
technology with massive over-labeling
and bead aggregates
the panel more on the right shows max
column technology
minimal labeling and smallest bead size
if you like to learn more about max cell
separation technology please follow the
link above
and indeed the results with our
enrichment cd 154 and cd 137 micro bit
kits are striking
pbmcs were stimulated to cmv pp65
peptides or left untreated
and then gen antigen activated t cells
were enriched using our cd 154 and cd
137 micro bit kits respectively
cells were then counterstrained for cd4
and cd8
as expected hardly any cell expressing
cd 154 or cd 137
can be found in the unstimulated samples
regardless of enrichment
after stimulation however antigen
specific t cells heavily upregulate the
respective markers
and can thereby be easily enriched for
any downstream analysis
with the cd137 and cd154 microbeads
miltoni biotech
offers the ideal tools to pre-enrich
activated
antigen-specific t-cells highest purity
and recovery are ensured
with the minimal labeling full
compatibility to all downstream
applications without effects on the cell
biology is ensured
of course the tesla related cell
separation portfolio is not limited
to cd 154 and cd137
but comprises solutions for the positive
and negative isolation
of several t-cell subsets including cd4
t-cells cd8-t cells and t-rex cells
make sure to have a look at the
respective technology paper by following
the respective link on the lower right
side
in this context the rapid rt protocol is
the perfect solution
it combines surface marker staining with
intracellular cytograin staining
but includes also an enrichment step
based on cd 154 expression
for even the rarest antigen specific cd4
positive t
cells first
pbmcs are stimulated with a specific
antigen
for some hours the t cells get activated
and upregulate accordingly activation
marker
cd 154 and release functional cytokines
cells are then stained for further
surface markers
including cd 154
next cells are enriched via cd 154
using max columns and further
intracellular staining for example for
cytokines
are performed directly on the column
then the enriched and stained
antigen-activated t-cells can be eluted
and easily analyzed via flow cytometry
in for example on our max quant analyzer
this approach is not only very fast with
the stein
staining directly on the column but also
extremely sensitive
due to the enrichment via cd154
cd 154 is as described before an
activation marker that is ideally suited
to enrich
rare antigen activated ct4 positive t
cells rapid rt may be modified
for cd8 positive t cells by using other
markers
for example cd 137 for enrichment
in this example here that you can see on
the right side as described by baja head
colleagues
pbmcs were stimulated with aspergillus
lysate for seven hours
stained for surface markers and
cytokines and enriched based on their
cd154 expression
the protocol enriched antigen-specific
t-cells
up to 85 times and thereby facilitated a
reliable analysis of aspergillus
reacting t cells
rapidart is the fastest and easiest
solution for the analysis of even the
rarest of antigen specific t cells
with frequencies below 0.01 percent of
total t
cells please also download the
application node rapidarte
on our t cell application page by
following the link in the upper right
side
however let's have a look at a virus
specific example
where the rta protocol was applied bbmcs
from covid19 survivors
and healthy donors were either
stimulated with a mix of starscoff2
peptibeters
a mix of influenza peptides
as controlled or left untreated
as seen in the middle panel the very
rare saskof2 specific cd4 positive
theses
were successfully enriched via cd 154
and visualized in flow analysis
the data was provided by the courtesy of
alexander sheffold and petra bacha
from the uk uksh in kiel germany
furthermore i want to point out a cell
separation product that
is absolutely unique the cytokine
secretion assays
they allow to detect and enrich viable
cytokine secreting cells from mouse and
human samples
cytokines are immobilized on the surface
of the secreting cells
by the so-called catch reagent basically
thereby the cells label themselves
with its own cytokines in a second step
the immobilized cytokines are then
labelled by a floor of four conjugated
antibodies
called detection reagent and can then be
detected
viably without intracellular staining in
the fluorocytometer
in an optional third step the
fluorophore labeled cytokine secreting
cells
can be specifically enriched and used in
downstream assays by using an
antifluorophore magnetic microbead
consequently our cytokine secretion
assays come in two versions
for flow detections only we have the
detection kits
for the separation of viable cytokine
security cells
we have the detection and enrichment
kits including the additional enrichment
step via the max column
as you can see the cytokine secretion
assay detection
and enrichment kits work very
efficiently to enrich
viable virus-specific t-cells based on
their cytokine secretion
pbmcs of a cmv positive donor were
stimulated for 4 hours with cmv
lysate the responding cells were then
stained and isolated according to the
secretion of tnf alpha
and interferon gamma using the
respective secretion assay cell
enrichment and detection kits
as you can see in the stimulated samples
a strong population of cytokine
secreting cd4
and cd8 positive t cells respectively
was enriched
in the unstimulated control sample
however no cytokine secreting t cells
were detected after enrichment
as briefly mentioned before talking
about flow analysis of rare
antigen-specific t-cells
one of the most important aspects is the
minimization of background
here the re-affinity recombinant
antibodies are the ideal tool
being recombinantly engineered we have
complete control over the sequence and
guarantee
highest purity and lotto lord
consistency
to significantly reduce background
hereby the fc receptor binding site was
mutated so
no unspecific specific fc binding occurs
and tedious fcr blocking can be
completely omitted
combined with our superbright propriety
biodiese
for clear population discrimination you
have the ideal and most precise tool for
flow analysis of rare cells
please again follow the respective links
to find more product informations as
well as our useful tool
the antibody panel builder to design
well-planned complex multi-color panels
with optimized flow cytometry antibodies
however we do not only look at
antibodies but
also have ready to use flow analysis
kits
ranging from pre-mixed antibody cocktail
to full-fledged in-depth kits
the rapid cytokine inspector combines
extracellular t-cell markers
staining with intracellular cytokine
staining for the analysis of activated
cd4 and ct-8 positive t-cells
the maxplex assays are designed for
determining concentrations of up to 12
soluble analytes in a single sample
for example secreted cytokines in cell
culture supernatants
and last but not least the eight color
immuno phenotyping kit human
allows from the evaluation of various
leukocyte subsets
in one kit for example monocytes
neutrophils
eosinophils tb and nk cell populations
and of course all of these kits are
compatible with the fast and convenient
express modes on the max quant analyzers
automating analysis and thereby not only
speeding it up
but also eliminating human errors
however we will later hear more about
that
make sure to have a look at the
respective promo video by following the
respective links in the right side
let's have a closer look at some of
these flow kits
for the mere flow staining without
enrichment of antigen-specific t-cells
the rapid cytokine inspector is the
ideal all-in-one kit
for the combined extra intracellular
staining of antigen-specific t-cells
thereby sub-type and activation-specific
surface markers as well as intracellular
cytokines are stained at the same time
the rapid cytokine inspector is ideal to
monitor antigen-specific t-cells with
frequencies
higher than 0.01 percent of the total
t-cell population
as said before for lower frequencies the
rapid rt protocol including the
enrichment step
is recommended applications for the
rapid cytokine inspector include
assessment of samples immune status or
testing of licorice
material for virus-specific cd4 and
cd8-positive t-cells
on the right side you can see how the
rapid cytokine inspector was compared
to standard intracellular staining
protocols
after the stimulation with cmv peptides
pp65
and ie frequencies of cmv specific cd4
and cd8 t cells were analyzed in pbmcs
thereby for example the frequency of
virus specific t cells in the
freezer products as said before can be
assessed
the rapid cytokine inspector performed
as good as the classical intracellular
staining
but yields the benefits of a much faster
protocols
and then less washing steps and thereby
less cell
loss as said before
the rapid cytokine inspectors is of
course compatible with the express modes
for automated data analysis on the max
quant analyzers
this example shows the successful
analysis of antigen-specific
cd8-positive t-cells producing
interferon gamma and il-2
after peptivator stimulation human pbmcs
were incubated with always house
peptidator cmv pp65 for six hours
and breveltin i was added after two
hours
the cells were then stained using the
rapid cytokine inspector for expression
of cd8
interferon gamma and interleukin-2
expression was then assessed with the
maxquant analyzer 10.
as you can see the stimulated cmv
specific cd8 positive t
cells nicely expressed c interferon
gamma
and il2 upon activation
finally we'd like to show you an example
where cd3 positive t cells were assessed
for interferon gamma
expression after stimulation with our
sarskoff two peptivators
a blood sample was lysed with an rbc
lysis buffer and stimulated for four
hours with the respective peptides
or left untreated subsequently cells
were stayed
using the rapid cytokine inspector-based
staining protocol interferon gamma
production by cd3-positive t-cells was
assessed
the plots clearly show that covid19
survivors show
elevated level of sars kof2 reactive t
cells
after stimulation with the respective
peptivators
another important aspect of
antigen-activated t-cell analysis
is the analysis of secreted functional
cytokines
here melting biotech offers as briefly
mentioned before
flow analysis kits for multi-parameter
analysis of soluble
cytokines in cell culture supernatants
the max black cytokine kits they are
designed for determining concentrations
of up to 12
human soluble analytes in a single
sample
the analysis is based on max plex
capture beads
which display defined fluorescent
properties and can be identified using
any multi-color standard flow cytometer
again in combination with the express
modes on the max quant analyzers however
the maxplex cytokine kits are optimized
for automated measurements and simplify
flow cytometric analysis
where predefined experimental settings
as well as acquisition
and analysis templates furthermore
additional variants of the maxplex kits
for example for mouse samples
exosome analysis or the analysis of
cytotoxic t and nk cells are available
so the maxplex assays allow real
multiplex assays
for secreted cytokines using any
standard flowstatometer
make sure to have also a look at the
respective webinar by following the link
on the right side
here we have an example how much plex
analysis
using the max quant express modes look
like pbmcs were stimulated
with cv peptides and the supernatant
for cytokine secretion the fast and easy
express most automate analysis
of unknown samples without user
dependent variations and result in most
reproducible analysis
as you can see here within minutes a
graphical representation as well as a
statistical display of the measured
cytokines
is emitted by the software
so what are these express modes exactly
express modes are software modules on
the max1 analyzers that automate flow
analysis with standardized
algorithm-based data evaluation
results become more standardized as
operator variability is minimized due to
a lack of manual intervention
and reduction of human error this
results in highest reproducibility with
identical flow analysis
independent from the operator
express modes are simple to use and
offer quick and robust analysis for easy
integration into sops
with the validated automated analysis
concept
several of our flow kits as the
aforementioned rapid cytokine inspector
max black cytokine kits the eight color
immunophenol typing kit
as well as specific flow panels for
example for car t cell analysis
are compatible with the express modes
again make sure to have a look at the
respective webinar by following
the respective link in the middle of the
page
in this context let's have a brief
excursion to our flow instruments from
the max quant series
first we have the max quant analyzer
powerful benchtop flow cytometers
with up to 16 optical parameters
the clue here is that they allow for
full automation
including acquisition using a robotic
sample collector with the express mode
software modules
even the data analysis is automated and
free of human error
second we have the max quant title cell
sorter
thanks to microchip sorting using a
microwolf the max plant title allows for
the most gentle cell sorting and highest
viability
even for rare and fragile cells
furthermore the closed and sterile
cartridge system
makes the title the ideal machine for a
gmp environment
it is worthwhile mentioning that of
course safety
and this kind of research comes first
the small benchtop cytometers fit easily
under the laminar flow cabinet and the
title cell sorter works without internal
fluidics
and applies a sterile enclosed cartridge
system for maximum
operator safety
here i'd like to have a closer look
especially at the max quantitative cell
sorter
with its unique capabilities namely the
most gentle sorting
and the closed derived cartridge system
the title is the ideal machine for a gmp
clinical environment
not only in the fields of car t cells
and t-rex but of course
also in the field of antigen specific t
cells
so let me point out that the title is
already part of several clinical
cancer trials involving antigen or beta
tumor-specific t
cells as you can see in the list on the
right side
of course i want to share an application
example for the sorting of cmv specific
cd8 positive t cells
using the title cell sorter
bbmcs from a cmv seropositive donor were
labeled with cmv
dextromere pe and cd8apc
and sorted with the maxquan title the
dot plot shows
pre-bmcs prior to sorting in the input
chamber
this cmv decks from a positive target
cell fraction after sorting
in the positive collection chamber and
the cell fraction depleted
of the cmv dextrovir positive cells in
the negative collection chamber
flow cytometry analysis was then
performed on the maxquant analyzer
as you can see cmv specific cd8 positive
t
cells were gently sorted with highest
purity to
of almost 94 percent
make sure to have a look at the
respective application node
and scientific poster by following the
respective links on the right side
to this end here you see a schematic
overview of our whole antigen-specific
test portfolio and workflow
from sample preparation to cell
separation to cell analysis
we cover the whole antigen-specific
t-cell workflow
please make sure to have a look at our
respective application website
for the virus-specific t-cells as well
as our webinar by following the links
below
to sum up the most important message is
that we will manage this virus crisis
together
t-cells play a fundamental role in the
antivirus immune response and their
analysis in this context
is very important there are
a lot of benefits from an efficient
virus-specific thesa research
apart from a better understanding of the
antivirus immune response
t-cell analysis in this context may
clarify important questions like
if re-infections are possible if other
coronary infections might provide
immunity
or which role secondary diseases might
play furthermore
analysing t cells in viral infections
will allow
a more exact prognosis on disease
progression
opening thereby a more reliable
assessment of action options
and may lead to better planning and
therefore hopefully a faster return to a
habitual life
resulting in also minimization of
economic damages
but most importantly we cover the whole
antigen and virus-specific t-cell
workflow
to assist you in your research
please also acknowledge the displayed
disclaimer
with this i come to an end of this
presentation thank you very much for
your attention
and stay healthy
you